even if you start
making a lot of money
I think it is really important not to up
your lifestyle too much now
why do I say this I grew up I grew up
with money right my dad it's a top one
percent earner I had nine siblings
um my parents I'm a software company
and growing up
we had a nice house
but our lifestyle
was never crazy
um we wore hand-me-downs
uh we barely ever ate out
on trips we never flew we always drove
and why do I think this was important
because we go off in the world
and if you get too used to a certain
lifestyle if the world goes south
you're gonna feel like you have to
maintain it have to maintain it and it's
why
even when I've you know done well
the YouTube stuff is taken off
you're never really gonna catch me
um
spending a lot of crazy
money on clothes
heavy makeup hair
because
at the end of the day none of that stuff
really matters
and especially women like
we will spend
so much
money
on makeup on Hair Botox all that
and my question is when you have
children
and a family
how are you going to maintain that
you know most
most women are average women right
and so most women
can't afford
to be spending two three grand a month
and you guys are putting yourself in
debt for what
when you could be saving the money
and it could be going
towards your family someday
but instead
it goes towards yourself and now what
does this symbolize in the culture what
is the show
it shows that we have a culture that
thinks about ourselves before the family
it shows we have a culture
that
thinks about like me me first and I had
this conversation in Miami
where they're asking how much a guy has
to give you a month
to not work
and I'm thinking
food shelter clothes are paid for what
what does he have to give you
extra money for these girls are telling
me they need two thousand dollars
to maintain them what does that mean
and when I said I didn't need that
they say to shoot higher
and I don't know what delusional world
we live in but like ladies most of us
are average most of us if you want to be
married will likely have to date an
average guy
so if your lifestyle is too expensive
you're gonna feel like you need to
maintain that when you get married
and
a lot of you it's not in the cards for
so
you really just have to think like what
is the trade-off you want in life you
know would you go down in lifestyle for
a family and unfortunately
the answer for a lot of women is no
and that's why we see 50 of women being
single childless
because
no guy will measure up because they're
so used to a crazy lifestyle when really
yeah when really you should be okay with
the guy making 40 to 60k a year but let
me know what you guys think in the
comments
maybe I'm wrong I don't know like the
video on your way out subscribe